a causeway across the bay connects
Markin to the mainland the sleepy island
is just 45 minutes from Amsterdam the
lighthouse has been keeping sailors on
course for more than 170 years Liliana
and ties spyker have been living in the
lighthouse Alex for 12 years now they
renovated it from the ground up turning
it into their dream home oh I was a
sailor before so I like the water in the
ship's and now I live in the water with
the ships around look around it's the
freedom its water it's nice weather and
of course also sometimes dead weather
that's why we love living me living in
the lighthouse they have 90 square
meters of living space over two levels
and everywhere that collection of naval
memorabilia reminds them of their great
passion the ocean
everything what happened with water and
chips and lighthouses I collect that's a
small small tick I make a special corner
my wife it's not amused with it I have
to clean it is easier that you were
coiler that's it a narrow spiral
staircase winds 15 meters of the tower
in years gone by it was manned by a
lighthouse keeper today the signal
beacon operates automatically but ty
spyker does carry out mine repairs and
he's added a few conveniences IV put
officiated on the under delight with a
few beers and a bottle of wine and a few
stairs with NH three beers you have to
go to the toilet so you could better sit
down stairs of a QB than upstairs not
everything has been fully modernized
though electricity is produced by a
generator about 200 meters away
it's peaceful and scenic with water as
far as the eye can see tap water comes
from tanks that need to be refilled with
water from the village once a month but
they've learned to live with the small
inconveniences well you have to be more
efficient you don't throw away it you
don't leave the tip open when you were
brushing your teeth the Spikers pay a
monthly rent of about 500 euros the
closest supermarket is two kilometers
away but they don't mind the isolation
we're not lonesome I think loneliness
you also do a lot by yourself if you
don't accept people if you don't talk to
people if you don't do anything to have
companion then you're lonely but no we
have a lot of friends we have a lot of
guests a lot of visitors
whatever the inconveniences they still
have what makes the most happy all
around them the sea for Liliana and ties
spyker living in a lighthouse is a dream
come true